[Music]
may 14th
cox business convention center prepares
for the funniest show
on
[Music]
fancy
earth
getting there is half the fun compare it
with me
moving right along
[Applause]
people can be whoever they want to be
and i think at the current times are are
going to change people can't be whoever
they want to be or whatever they want to
be i believe they can there are
biological and physiological limitations
to everybody after a couple of months of
hormone therapy a couple months or a
year it doesn't make that much of a
difference
now now what if that was entirely
incorrect
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
stranger
[Music]
ah
oh it tastes fishy you made it
that's the last time i do that's the
last time i stir my honey in with fish
sticks
damn you gordon's
so it's maxwell house fish morning yes
the best part of waking up is fungus in
your cup now trout yes
actually we have some material today on
uh on the fish because of uh china and
how they're testing for kovid but we
have matt gates on the show today don't
say gates
i'm not in florida i can say and i can
i'm not in florida we're in texas and i
can say gates don't say that i can say
gates it's his name the bill doesn't
even say don't say gates
it says don't say gay and that's not
even in the bill at all now you're
confusing me
so before i move on uh i guess my
question of the day to you is uh mark
zuckerberg robot human what do you think
you can comment below we're going to be
talking about this um all i can call
them is uh uh someone of whom i'm not a
fan so we'll be talking about that we'll
be talking about what's going on in uh
in china i don't know if you know that's
been praised for their handling of the
kovid uh and uh of course now they're
committing gross atrocities of human
rights
in uh against human rights in china you
know i rep do i need it it's redundant
but still it will have some funny clips
um
and important to know anytime this show
is not on youtube
because there's been some interviews
with matt gates that have been removed
really yep they've been removed from
youtube in the past i say gates i can
say gates uh you can follow us on rumble
or
on mug club where we have an entire
additional we have an entirely
additional one hour show
every single day 69 for students
veterans active military and uh yeah no
show next thursday just so you know
that's you so don't be looking for us on
youtube next thursday but monday through
thursday 10 a.m eastern if you don't see
us on youtube unless we otherwise tell
you just head on over to rumble or mug
club because sometimes youtube just says
remember how you ran your business we're
not going to let you do that anymore ah
they're like the us government i got it
yes effectively uh what else are we
talking what else are we talking about
today we're gonna be talking about mark
zuckerberg oh brian oh that's gonna be
fun brian stealth
he's a huge disney fan well he's more so
a fan of the disney pedophilia oh
there's that part yes he defends them on
that's like park huh come on bro just
does anyone discuss with him the optics
yeah well he gets free cotton candy yes
he does and by that i mean they
literally hold him up by his feet like a
swirly just
in the cotton candy machine
dwarfs how much can i fit
all of it who knew he's also the guy
that sent all the other correspondents
from cnn to ukraine to cover the world
live it'll be great for your career he's
just like you guys are the ukraine
russia war correspondents and i am the
cotton candy correspondent that's what i
do it's just hoping they don't come back
we all have our thing okay stop
complaining all right
[Laughter]
moving on up we all put our we all put
our pants on the same way with one strap
to pull it up at a time now one
suspender at a time one suspender at a
time
it's more of a stroke really uh you know
him you love him gerald a is here how
are you sir i am doing well how are you
i'm okay my neck's getting a little bit
better there you go my neck hurts it
turns into a migraine ah yeah yeah so i
thought i was your headache cause most
of those well that was gonna say you too
thank you but it also didn't help that
you you know karate chop my neck
that doesn't work yeah i don't know by
the way congratulations on your black
belt your mom's check cleared and you
know him you love him he's going to be
uh in rialto square theater on april 8th
joliet ileana and then he's going to be
in waukegan indiana the genesee theater
april 9th
illinois illinois you said indiana last
time did i say ileana said ileana
admonished this i just i absolutely need
which is i need a break it is definitely
uh
it's kind of a place though because
there is a border there well there's
it's close well jackson 5 are from gary
indiana which is basically ileana this
is a really really good sign for how the
interview with matt gates is going to go
i i think you have early onset dementia
i do i have whatever bruce willis has
someone in an earpiece just needs to
coach me on human interactions you and
joe biden
i'm gonna have to say the line
uh like i understand what words are so
dave linda how are you ahoy how are you
good well obviously from this well yes
you're doing well it's almost like a day
when you host i know
hey
my joke what's the bruce willis disease
being a dick
[Laughter]
it actually is that too well yes yes who
knew side effects i heard he's not a
nice man uh really well yeah but come on
can you blame him i just realized i had
to
which by the way we have these tumblers
at uh i think
there you go guys go to crowdershop.com
all right before we move on to anything
else you can go see dave it's a lot of
credit.com tour we have some dates uh
ourselves
pretty
checked
it's about it's about sold out if you
don't buy it today what's the date today
today is the seventh if you're not
purchasing them today in the seventh
maybe the morning of the eighth they're
probably gone but we are doing a fall
tour that we'll add dates to and there's
still some tickets in colorado springs
so
not a bunch that's for the second show
yeah for the second show yes
all right those are going fast too
though before anything else will smith
he's an actor you know this uh-huh is he
yes he's an actor he's a professional uh
slap fighter uh track star and now yeah
clean rapper
yes
yeah you know it's like isn't it funny
it's like the bill cosby like i don't
know what listen eddie murphy you don't
you have to use all the bad ones hold on
i gotta go rape
you use the airport and will smith's
like i don't like putting uh bad words
in my hip hop uh but you know i like
watching my wife uh copulate with other
men i'll also swear at a guy after
hitting him at an award show but never
in my music right never in my music like
wow what a great man you are getting
dicky with it so
he's a track star he's an actor and
apparently now i have not seen this i
guess he's a good tennis player
oh
oh will
that's why i hate you that's why i hate
non-contact sports is it my tennis balls
out your mouth
i don't think that's what i don't think
he would be wanting that
keep my tennis balls out put them in my
wife's
yeah my wife is over there yeah and when
she leaves i'm going to have fun with
you yes
because it's a scientologist way let me
test your themes put your thumbs on this
we boys for life
bad boys bad boys yeah that's what i
meant yeah
i'm so bad i'm so bad that i let my wife
bring me up on a podcast called the red
table and humiliate me in front of the
world
demasculinized me by letting everybody
know that she was sleeping with a 20
year old rapper who was my daughter and
son's friend yes i sat there and took it
i'm a bad boy wait is that don't you
mess with me
is that real yes it's real that's
exactly what happened she slept with a
rapper who was friends with their uh one
of their children i knew it was bad i
didn't realize it was that bad basically
had to
kind of go back and say it was an open
marriage to you know
you had to cover this yeah yeah the
tracks i thought you were cheating on me
but i said that we were in an open
marriage okay you're right you're right
yeah that's true that was this like fine
print that he didn't read yeah exactly
yeah that's oh
he could have anybody
yeah he chose her yeah
you see her in gotham
she can't maintain an accent they just
wrote it out
liam neeson can do an accent liam neeson
would be better as that black female
character in gotham than jada pink sean
connery would be better yeah exactly
have you seen the penguin have you seen
my english russian accent
i have a very particular set of skills
can you do uh you do midwestern that's
not amongst them no that is
not one of them i can attempt it but it
won't be the whole time also i can't
really fight because i'm like 72 and i
can't make movies other than ones where
i fake like i can fight by the way i'm
from poughkeepsie can you fast forward a
kick yes yes make it fast just fast
forward also can you have a stand-in for
the kick
they're going to take you and i'm fine
with it yes
my back hurts they're going to take you
and i'm going to take some uh probably
vicodin and just zone out in the couch
that's what i'm going to do i paid them
to take you yes
i will find you
[Laughter]
all right speaking of left left to see
there's a segway i like it i'm doing a
autobiographical film about the man who
rode his segway off a cliff
the problem is that's about the only uh
really interesting part of the story is
he invented the segway then he died in a
segway riding it off a cliff and this
happened in arizona which is where i'm
from in this film arizona that's my
voice
brilliant the movie is me just laying
there yes it's really dead me
laying there
dead
and then people laughing and then yeah
paramedics going ah then i duct tape
some broken glass to my neck
and fight wolves that's exactly what i
was thinking
okay so uh in a recent interview with
tim ferriss you know this for a guy who
always talks about the four-hour work
week seems to be doing a lot more than
four hours of work yeah yes work week
four hours yeah that's what he said four
whole hours yeah i don't know these guys
are just robots are different than i
always want to find these excuses like
you can work four hours like you mean by
selling everyone else on working four
hours and you do seminars anyway i don't
have anything against tim ferriss i have
to say that so
tim ferriss
and uh mark zuckerberg said that mark
zuckerberg said in an interview with tim
ferriss that um meta employees and for
you saying meta that's what he wants you
to refer to facebook
it's not a thing
it's like inventing your own nickname in
a sport you're like i think i should be
like the dentist skull crusher they're
like uh how about queerbait that's your
name
your nickname is is queerbait that's
what it is yes it's joseph queerbait
smith like i was really thinking that
i'd be like what joseph one punch
knockout how about joseph nobody likes
you
[Laughter]
go change the toilet paper rolls
in the men's room smith so mark
zuckerberg said of meta employees if
they refer to him
not knowing this is a bad thing as the
eye of sauron
i do think managing energy is an
interesting thing i mean some of the the
folks who i work with the company they
say this lovingly but i think that they
sometimes remember my attention is the
eye of sauron
in that basically
you have this unending amount of energy
to go work on on something and if you
and if you like point that at any given
team you will just burn them
they say that lovingly like they say
lovingly at the office they refer to me
as as himmler yeah
that's the term of endearment they say
there we go there goes mr himmler yeah
it's weird when i did they call me
christ killer term of endearment exactly
at first i just thought it was
anti-semitic but then it turned out it
was just anti-semitic yeah they call me
[ __ ] for brains yeah they throw shoes at
me right you know
that's how you know they love you yep
real team building experience i take
them out to go carts yep they call me
lockjaw because for some reason i talk
like this right yeah that's just you
know and sometimes you know they have
their pet names they have lockjaw they
have you know christ killer [ __ ] and
it's just these are they're all in good
fun
christmas haircuts even though i have
billions of dollars right no idea why i
just uh i'd rather you know wear a bowl
yeah wear a bowl on a rotating chair
yep i love bill gates love his hair i
love it he's like if i focus on any one
particular thing i kill everyone on the
team right it's like oh good you're ceo
great awful person you first
so i stole this whole idea
right two guys
i burned them they call me thief in the
night right because i took this all
right they call me don't trust him yeah
it's just that's what my best friends
call me yeah the closest people to me
yeah my own my own parents and i just
refer to people by their private
password because that's how i remember
them when i can access their stuff
that's see that's four three two one
right there uh what should my nickname
give us a nickname for me gerald dave
what should our nicknames be comment
below because hey it's fun that helps
with the youtube algorithm and uh make
them as offensive as possible
particularly for gerald we'll cover this
in the uh the chat for the the mud
clubbers that's true we will cover them
for the chat about clubbers and then
we'll probably read the best ones next
week from youtube okay here's another
story
again we have matt gates on the show
we're talking about shows
you know what fine i'll just say gets
leo gets bernie bernie gets he's so good
with the dog
was the guy who killed the subway people
i was thinking of davey berkowitz it
doesn't matter these references these
references are not particularly timely
i mean they're always they're timeless
really but you know i mean i'll find a
way to shoehorn cardi b in there please
do ah please don't i'm done well not
shoehorn so much as you know like crane
the way she's been shoehorned into all
of our lives yes the way they shoehorn
her into her leather pants yes
and by that i mean ass funnel they just
she has to slide down the mcdonald's
kids slide into a pair of pants
already at mcdonald's somewhere as well
have you had your break today
is that the still the slogan of
mcdonald's have you had a break today
what is it i think it's i'm loving it is
it still i'm loving it oh well that
still works she's definitely loving it i
think it's sorry that all those happy
meals cost your kid his eye
so uh brian stelter who i'm so glad is
not off the air yeah uh and
if you genuinely i really i want him to
stay me too i have a recurring character
scenes
and he's also you remember when you were
a kid and you had the cereal boxes like
you get like a dinosaur you know fruity
pebbles and you would it would say hey
it turns into a giant dinosaur you just
put it in water and it like grows
slightly yeah it's very disappointing
right but it looks bloated yes
okay so brian stelter was defending
disney
against critics calling the criticisms
against the backlash you'll understand
exactly what i was talking about uh
to the lgbtq acceptance so he decided to
go in to defend disney here's brian
stelter the talking point on the right
is about protecting kids from the
dangers of just enough bigger the walt
disney company
really
yes but disney's just
a stand-in it's just a symbol for
something bigger a conservative backlash
to growing acceptance of gay and
transgender people but the media organs
that profit from conflict are on a
crusade now working overtime to demonize
disney claiming the company
indoctrinating and sexualizing children
for three movies and tv shows 100 yep
i don't you have i mean any rebuttals to
that yeah yeah and he was like they're
just saying that they're sexualizing
children
yeah you're saying they're not well no
they are but i just but you're just
you're saying that as well
yeah i believe my work here is done yes
do you have a dr seuss shirt with a neck
hole yes
also do you have a dr pepper 19 dr
peppers yes please i require them
everyone knows i can't start my program
without 19 dr peppers two liters 19
2-liter dr peppers
and um my uh my my catheter do you have
my murse yes my catheter murse i mean
gym bag it's my gym bag it's super
straight so again i am it's just really
bizarre that he decides to defend disney
on this
uh
just you know what let's say that you
real i get it you really are hoping for
moana too okay
you know what picture frozen three kind
of guy yeah well frozen yogurt yes
i'd love a spin-off frosty with fries
you ever dip your fries in frosties no i
know they're trying to sell us on that
it's disgusting says you it's good
so of course by the way it could also be
cnn has its own history with pedophiles
right they have not to mention all the
other sex offenses that have taken place
in cnn it's a lot of articles um that's
just a scoop of them yeah and and the
backlash against disney is backlash
against and youtube is saying this is a
conspiracy but it's actually against uh
left-wing grooming grooming of children
but it isn't some new term that was
invented by a q a called the term
grooming is one that is used by people
who uh traffic children or sex offenders
with those who are underage to try and
get them comfortable and desensitized to
the idea of a hyper-sexualized situation
this is something i have experience with
because salon had an article this was a
long time ago and was called him a
pedophile but i'm not a monster and we
actually did some research and found
this pedophile and he was bragging about
grooming children on message boards
ultimately salon ended up pulling those
articles only after the evidence was
completely irrefutable it was so
insurmountable that you know they just
removed it rather than apologizing so
grooming is a thing it's an actual term
that's been used for a long time and
people are now saying it seems as though
disney has gone so far
and places like netflix but right now
disney is more aggressive with the
florida
not don't say gabriel that's how they
refer to it that
we now can appropriately refer to it as
grooming here's the thing the employees
of disney
the employees of disney were the ones
who said it
our leadership over there has been so
welcoming to like my like not at all
secret gay agenda many many many lgbtqia
characters
in our stories they've been really open
to exploring queer stories and kind of
the only way to have that
beer canonical trans characters
canonical asexual characters canonical
bisexual characters is to give them
stories where they can like be their
whole selves it looks like a character
that a woman would try to create in
world of warcraft only it didn't work
yeah
it looks like a character in world war
ii
like like the world of warcraft but it
can't actually wield the axe but yeah
come on all right just rape me i really
didn't know which here's my impression
of his dad getting a phone call from him
voicemail
or just auto text driving yeah yeah
dad you drive a lot yes yeah it's all i
do son that's all i do christmas isn't
uh again this year you know covered yeah
how the water was over yeah no not for
us no i got it for the 19th time yeah
i'm on the uh i'm on a you hear that
oh i'm on a ventilator thing yeah can't
see you can't see you did you so did you
notice what brian stelter said about
this so obviously he knows that this
information is out there but he says
this is a pushback against us accepting
lgbtq and trans people specifically if i
lumps them in together well but
accepting them we're not accepting them
by not teaching five-year-olds about
this stuff about sex eventually that
conversation goes to sex yeah right
that's that's what he's trying to say
that's what he's trying to say they're
always trying to go the intolerance
route right exactly
this is a question i genuinely have for
people i was just talking with someone
the other day who became more of a
conservative like in 2008 voted for
trump but lived in california so wasn't
really a conservative wasn't
right-leaning
and
living there said i had a lot of gay
friends i thought okay love is love mary
whoever you want to marry and i
understand that i understand that people
want to be empathetic i do i genuinely
understand that people don't want to
infringe upon other relationships but i
asked this person i said okay
so
back in 2015 i believe this was with
dave rubin
uh he said you know when people like you
and me crowder are you know we're we're
more libertarian and you know i know
you're pro gay marriage and i said no
not you said what i said well i'm
explaining to you i'm not civil unions
you're talking about that you're talking
about property sharing you're talking
about will you're talking about hospital
visit of course absolutely but here's
the deal i wish that government were not
in the church running business in the
marriage business but they are
government recognizes marriages between
a man and a woman why because we
understood before federal government we
understood before state government
before municipal government we needed to
have a form of self-governance and the
most effective form of self-governance
as a nuclear family we created these
laws to recognize marriage to
incentivize the best possible scenario
for rearing children now you may not
like that but that's why it exists so i
said if we understand the historical
context as to why that's marriage this
was i believe in 2015.
i said to say that men and women are to
say that anyone can is to say that men
and women are fundamentally
interchangeable
and i don't think that's a slope you
want to go down and here we are today
and i even said before you guys say this
let me cut you off of the past what
about people who are against interracial
marriage well i think this is something
that a lot of people have felt uh is or
maybe they felt but weren't able to
articulate it most people who were
against same-sex marriage back in the
day were not against interracial
marriage here's why uh
a man and a woman are far different than
a man and a black man or a white woman
and a black woman so assuming the same
socio-economic status assuming you know
no history of drug abuse right taking an
equivalent white woman and a black woman
i believe that a black mother can
provide everything to a child that a
white mother can
i don't believe there's anything missing
there same thing a black father a black
or a white father i believe that a black
father can provide anything that a white
father can i do not believe that two
fathers can provide everything that a
mother can i do not believe that two
mothers can provide everything that a
father can that's why marriage man and
woman that's the ideal to raise children
it's very different from interracial
marriage and if you say well marriage is
anything that's the first step towards
saying there are no gender roles men and
women are fundamentally interchangeable
that was my argument back then
2022 do you think that it holds water
and i asked this person the other day i
said has this lgbtq aaip force you to go
back and re-examine you know i think was
prop 12 when we were in california yeah
uh first you could to go back and
re-examine that and she said absolutely
she had 100 so i didn't really know it
was what i still would love for people
to be able to have civil union but
looking back i see that it was a
slippery slope and here we are and i
just can't believe it well and we've
argued this like you said since 2015 we
argued before then we argued back in
2005 and 2010 any time that this has
come up we're like okay be careful it
didn't take long right it didn't take a
generation it took a matter of years for
us to get to the clown show that we were
living in today yeah yeah so i want to
know if if people out there right now
many of you were not conservatives right
you watching you're listening right now
in 2015
2014
has it forced you to go back and look at
these situations which were once
considered moral issues of the right and
go you know what
maybe they had a point comment below so
um while we're talking about
disney
they just admitted it on camera uh let
me give you a briefer
on their well sorry a briefer only on i
don't have that much time i can't go
back to walt disney in his this is an
elastic
uh just the child sex offenses
35 disney employees have been arrested
for child sex crime since 2006. what
that's a real problem 17 were arrested
in august 2021.
just
oh just 17 yeah a child predator sting
is this like a they get like a package
deal or something i guess they did help
i mean i think they threw a dart into a
disney conference table and there was
like how many however many darts they
threw that's how many child sex
offenders they hit it's them and kyle
rittenhouse who knew so let me give you
some specific examples just so you know
you know
it's not an 18 year old guy with a 17
year old girlfriend uh in october 2019 a
guy named oliver levat disney cruise
line youth host was arrested for lewd
and lascivious battery of a child under
12 years old june 2020 get that job
uh well they have a not so secret gay
agenda dave yeah exactly so he just said
well i'm gay and they're like well we
love you that's fantastic i think
they're probably giving softer
background checks if someone is lgbtq
aip i'm not even joking about that i
think they're going no let's just make
sure that we get them through like oh
this guy did some hard time for rape
well you know what we all made mistakes
you can be youth hosts
yes yes it's an honorary position yeah
unsupervised youth host can you play an
instrument we'd like to put you in the
next uh next disney rock themed program
you can just lip sync you know what we
don't even need a lip sync we'll just
get a korean to do it
why do you call this part of your ship
neverland yes that's weird that's
because parents are never to go here yes
you never get out big fan of michael are
we yes and they have a chimpanzee on red
wine and xanax so june 2020 walt disney
world employs justin
hazaan or hazen and uh orlandra sims
arrested for possession of child
pornography at least they were arrested
yeah unlike if they worked for the fbi
well uh march 2022 four disney employees
were caught in a child predator sting in
florida it's sort of like with kyle
rittenhouse where he shot one
multiple-time child rapist and then a
domestic abuser you just have to at a
certain point go wow it's almost
impossible to if you just slap the air
randomly
you're going to hit a child sex offender
if you're in a group of leftist
activists
that's what i made the point a minute
ago it's like it's kyle rittenhouse and
these guys doing a bulk deal how did we
know oh oh it's just so disgusting for a
long time
i mean also here's what it is it just it
just bothers me so much like this is the
stuff that you grow up on this is the
stuff that you're supposed to show your
kids you want them to learn and it's
just violated by these it's just it's
it's gross also here's another question
that we're not how do you get to 17
arrested in a child sex ring at disney
do you have any idea if they're let's
say that it happens to be a small
project too you know what i mean like
that's like a little thing that they did
maybe it was a day maybe it was two i
don't know how long it was but sting
operations don't take very no they don't
take very long and that's how many they
were able to catch in a short amount of
time right because they were meeting at
the
sex table they were meeting at the sex
conference the underage sex table they
had a plaque yeah on the office well
think about how much disney pays in
taxes and everything else like a lot of
stuff had to go on before they were even
able to set up that sting opera that's
how they found them yeah like 12 year
old boys are not a write-off
yeah they're like
that's not a business it's a business
expense no it is well it's a stress
relief if i can't have my 12 year old
boy i can't do my work all right mr
pixar i think this has gone
far enough the degeneracy but think if
someone in this office
yeah mouse if if someone in this office
were to even remotely suggest that they
were attracted to minors i'm not going
to lie to you that person would
disappear yeah i'd kill them yeah that
person would disappear let alone to
recruit 17 people at the office think
about that they were comfortable enough
to have 17 people in the disney offices
say like all right okay we're not gonna
not only confident enough to tell 17
people but confident enough that there
was so much buy-in from the other 17
child rapists that none of them would
say a word that's i i've never met h
maybe i haven't i didn't know child
rapist in my life yeah let alone 17
in an open an open layout office i mean
they're open layout offices
look over their shoulder every now and
then yeah i walk in the security camera
room and they're just circling stuff
like madden though you're right they're
like oh this is my cup of tea here
here's a 12 year old boy who you know
but he looks like he's 16 so we're going
to go back to the nine year old there
you go
go ahead groom them
is it any surprise i mean come on the
content that disney has been putting out
lately and they have shown that their
agenda is not family friendly and i
don't know that it ever really has been
there's been some times where maybe it
was on the line but you know there's
things about can you see the penis in
the sculpture and the the the you know
whatever the poster is that's silly
though no that's silly stuff i get it
and i'm not saying that that was what
led to this necessarily but i draw those
on your car with my keys yeah you're the
guy
are you the penis master yeah i know
what we told you it was hail damage
that's what i that's what i told my
insurance company as well it was hailing
rocket ships they were rocket ships
falling out of this i swear yeah and
printing on my car
okay in charge of amazon i drove by a
produce a produce stand he threw a
zucchini i don't know how this happened
weird yeah some oranges you know like 11
zucchinis
and then it hailed curly hair on the
well i know no no you're no but you're
absolutely right this is um
look look people didn't draw a line
before
no one
who has any history with child sex
should be working in any type of an
industry that involves children period
you're gone at all you're gone
not even the same zip code the fact that
it's not
a horrific penalty and we've talked
about that on the show before it boggles
my mind right we don't protect our
children in the society at all no no and
i don't get it and we all talk about
like like we do but we're not we're very
archaic about it well because you have
to ask the question what is innocence
and the truth is innocence would also
include a child not knowing about
homosexual activity because they
shouldn't know about
private sexual activity so this is just
an extension of that and that a teacher
doesn't need to let you know what's
going on in their bedroom when they go
but they consider that they can set up
an abuse of human rights over there in
florida yeah and now at disney they say
well this is who i am it's more i want
to make sure that everyone feels
comfortable about what i do well guess
what maybe they shouldn't yeah well and
by the way this is desantis's
opportunity to stand up like there are
some tax benefits that they're giving he
actually made a statement that maybe
it's time to revisit all of this if
they're not looking out for our
community why do we want that business
here so let's let's take away some of
the incentives yeah you guys want to
leave california we'll welcome you with
open arms you can screw that state up
even more if you would like to sorry
californians we know a lot of you watch
this right here it's time to leave
california yeah it is it's time to leave
but that being said just don't leave a
few you know if you if you vote
democrats stay right stay right where
you are stay in your pocket i don't even
know why you would live in california
let alone los angeles where it's like i
bought a four million dollar house
there's uh 9 000 homeless people living
in front of it yes yeah like i'm not
saying that there's anything you know
i'm not trying to attack homeless people
but i'm just saying that that's why you
stay there because they can attack the
homeless people without repercussions
well yeah that's right at that point
yeah it's a game that they play in
california yeah it's just a sad thing
it's just this drug disease drugged out
disease-filled
horrible place just like new york hey
what what is the commonality here now
before let me let me get to this before
i know you're talking about disney and
then uh we have uh matt gates uh on the
show today i understand there were
allegations okay it's like we're in
texas i can say it's just here you're
misconstruing the you need to read the
bills in the show map before we do the
show dave so uh
representative matt getz
gates thank you don't say gates gets
uh there were allegations obviously last
uh last year about sex trafficking so i
want to address this first off people
are innocent until proven guilty but we
just presented to you were people who
were caught people who pled guilty at
disney or people who were convicted um
before you guys say anything let me be
really clear there have been no charges
there have been no convictions and there
have been there been allegations the
only convictions that have actually
taken place is stephen alford pled
guilty on november 22nd for trying to
extort 25 million dollars from gates uh
and his family ah that's the only crime
that has actually been committed thus
far so everybody's just basically you
know throwing a lot of mud and then
somebody actually gets convicted for
trying to extort someone yeah do you
understand how that works and i
understand that there's an investigation
but they're
just like a lot of people in the capital
there have been no charges
investigation been going on been going
on for about a year very long time i
remember hearing about this from some
people and they were like oh the fbi is
involved oh this is gonna this isn't
gonna be good for you and you're a
left-leaning friend of mine oh yeah and
i was like oh okay well i don't i don't
know a whole lot about this right now
and then like time goes by i'm like hey
how about that investigation right right
yeah that's weird oh hey do you see the
name yeah yeah i'm trying to extort him
yes weird a year long it's like but how
could i maybe find pedophiles at disney
i don't know maybe i'll just flip a coin
there we go 17 who knew yeah have you
gone there with a team for three hours
on a sunday right yeah done
they don't even honor the sabbath that's
what's it pissed me off most offensive
it's shabbos dude so uh something else
too people i do appreciate when people
are actually doing so governor desantis
is actually doing something yeah in
florida and by the way keep in mind that
you know people think disney disney
world florida but guess what there's a
lot of money going into florida uh that
has nothing to do with florida right
these are money this is money that's
coming in internationally yeah coming in
uh well even in the disney company there
are people you know you have people
raising money in new york to try and
influence politics in florida yeah
florida should be just like a country
should be uh advocating for the best
interests of its people so should a
state
that's we really need to get to the
point where states can be as independent
as humanly possible so that you can see
a clear difference florida california
and that's about as close as you're
going to get florida texas california
they're pretty good comparison states as
far as population size as far as land
mass as far as you know diversity of
population and you can see some pretty
stark differences it's as close to a
control group as you will get
you guys decide for yourselves which one
you think is doing better so going to
texas yesterday uh governor greg abbott
he's in a wheelchair you know announced
a new plan to help address the state's
illegal border crossing issue by uh by
pulling a fast one to help local
officials whose communities are being
overwhelmed by hordes of illegal
immigrants who are being dropped off by
the body administration
texas
is providing charter buses
to send these illegal immigrants who
have been dropped off administration
to washington d.c
we are sending them to the united states
capitol where the body administration
will be able to more immediately address
the needs of the people that they are
allowing to come across our border
so this is because we talked about this
earlier this week and go to the show by
administration no longer enforcing the
immigration laws under title 42 with the
pandemic going on a national health
crisis so he is sending
uh
illegal immigrants
from the border because texas all the
way into washington dc so that they can
actually deal with it themselves people
over there in washington he's basically
getting a little bit of his own medicine
here
what's uh oh what's happening hola is
this washington dc no this is not
washington dc how are you uh i was on a
bus to dc and i had to get off because i
needed to uh use the little chicas room
but she could you know you can't use our
you can't use our chicas you can't use
the bathroom you gotta pay uh the chicas
room no you can't you can't use our
ladies room that's not of course not no
i'm friends you're not trans you're not
this is not yes i'm the elden the g and
the b and the t and the g no r s and the
t no he's not just saying abc's now i
said my
abc's okay next time on okay get out
me get down you have to go go you have
to go
i told you to leave okay i don't have
your murray oh but actually i do have
your oh no oh wait he does that was my
dad i'm sorry i have your
[Music]
there's a car that's been keyed you can
use yeah
thanks dave it's viva la raza i know
you're you're a
kind man
i don't even get him started on the
conjunction junction what's your
function he just he doesn't do it very
well no you had just told him where his
maracas were all we could have avoided
all of this i do love that they're
sending them to dc and i know a lot of
people say well we need to send the
national guard down to the texas border
look take the win where you can yeah
it's kind of trolling from the governor
but it's fun it's awesome
how many times too can you sit on the
national guard for stuff like this
that's enough already they've done
enough yeah exactly there's only so much
you can send them into dc see what they
can do yeah well that's what i wanted to
do yeah
let old empty heads see what he let's
let some uh let some congressmen and
senators have to compete for their jobs
yes somebody's willing to work for four
dollars an hour
probably do about the same job as aoc
they do a way better job oh they do a
way better job if they did nothing yeah
just sitting around so here's something
else going on before we bring on uh matt
gates don't say it don't
say it
uh for two years now we've heard this
from the state media who doesn't look
again doesn't look out for your own
interests this is the idea of
nationalism
and by the way smash that like button if
you're watching on uh on youtube because
uh you know youtube doesn't like us if
you search
for steven crowder interview with matt
gates guess what you're not going to
find it here on youtube so if you hit
the like button you leave a comment it
helps with the algorithm so
nationalism people have tried to equate
it with ethno-nationalism
they've tried to equate it with racism
right they've tried to equate as though
the only people who were ever
nationalists were nazis and by the way
we ignore the part of their
their party title that's socialist
the national socialist party
so being a nationalist just means that
you're proud of your country and you
look out for the best interests of your
country now here's the thing all
countries since the beginning of time
have done that
that gives you a good idea as to which
countries have done a good job so even
the crappy countries and what do you
mean crappy countries you know i mean
like countries that are inferior to
united states like most south american
countries most asian countries you know
crappy so they look out for their own
best interests they just do so poorly
nationalism
as it relates to americans means you
think that america should put its own
citizens first for example do we still
have vets who need health care and
they've served their country maybe
they're homeless maybe we should help
them before we send billions of dollars
to the to to the
crisis going on ukraine and russia just
a thought yeah just an idea just a
thought
right do we still have some debt maybe
we should start paying that off before
we start uh you know absolving all
student loans so that everyone who went
to a trade school or started a business
gets to pay for someone's gender studies
master degree just a thought maybe
so nationalism do not let i will tell
you this don't let anyone put you on
your heels i want you to reclaim that
bill yeah i'm a nationalist i believe
this is the greatest nation on earth
because of how we treat people of all
different races of all different genders
all stripes color sizes that's why i'm a
nationalist what you think it's better
to be a nationalist in china
for minorities you think it's better to
be a nationalist in venezuela you think
it's better to be a take your pick any
other country
it's a so i i just say that because i
see it a lot this is the tactic of the
left they equate nationalism with racism
with nazism therefore you should be
ashamed and shut up don't shut up say
sure i'm a nationalist what else you got
so for two years now we've had people
who are internationalists
those who work in state media those who
work in your government the elites right
who line their pockets and aren't
subject to insider trading laws former
ambassadors shills
and of course those
now we can also discuss those in china
um who have always discussed and sold
you this false bill of goods
that china handled kovid superbly here
you go if you really won't believe what
people are saying
then you should believe what people in
china are doing in the past few weeks
stores and restaurants reopened people
are getting back to work hospitals are
not overrun with patients i think that's
an american faking a chinese accent two
months ago
again life is surprise dreamweaver isn't
playing that is solid to prove how the
situation is improving china can you
really hide infectious
whether you believe china state or not
we don't doesn't affect the people
living in china but i wanted to really
explore the reason why
you think that that
china has done so so well
and many western countries have really
handled it quite poorly now i i would
suggest that it's a lot of it is down to
to the government and how serious they
take it yeah frankly they're taking
cobit probably more seriously than any
other country
i mean zero lockdown is pretty serious
um
my chinese friends tell me they don't
they don't mind is there a lockdown that
is they don't mind the inconvenience
um they're tested virtually every time
they turn around further supply chain
disruptions that's gonna have adverse
consequences economically in china but
also for the united states uh because
our supply chain is going to be a bit
disrupted so i take my hat off to how
strongly china's working on this better
than we are frankly by far
yeah there's a guy who's looking out for
your best interest communist china is
doing it but now here's the the why
communist china is doing it better
because they're stripping their citizens
of their rights and their citizens are
okay with it i wish we were more like
china this guy was a representative
of the united states citizens are you
starting to get the picture yeah oh the
easter island ted was yeah yeah he was
he was a senator he was also our guy in
china he was interested in china oh so
apparently things aren't going as
swimming and by the way all references
are available at lighteroscrider.com
link is in the pinned comment so you can
go and watch more footage than you could
see in a lifetime
not working so well in china now i would
say even if it worked out right
pragmatically it would still be morally
reprehensible because you don't have the
right to lock down citizens and strip
them other rights sure that being said
it still hasn't worked how do i know
china now has the worst outbreak since
the pandemic began yesterday 20 000
cases
a new single day record 13 000 cases in
shanghai alone and let me just say
something it's that's uh you know
china's uh reporting which means it's
it's it's likely very low now i know
what you're saying why are you saying
that stephen because they lie
uh well but here's the data that we were
given and then no no let me clarify the
chinese
lie no no really the communist chinese
party i should clarify the communists
they like to lie are you saying like how
they lied at the beginning of kovac yeah
yeah yeah yeah and said that it was
started by the united states military
yeah exactly so okay i don't trust them
not because i'm racist but because they
enjoy lying the way some people enjoy
fine wines yes gerald absolutely
give me a guess how many people you
think have been reported to have died
from covet since the beginning of the
pandemic according to that article that
we referenced one guy in his red wagon
in china in china
um do you think it's hundreds of
thousands do you think it's millions do
you think it's tens of thousands give me
give me your best guess this is a trick
question because i'm willing to bet
there's just one guy stuffed in a ballot
box
yes how many do are they claiming one
one yeah and they're saying wow i didn't
literally they're literally saying in
this article now again
you gotta go fact check this and make
sure right but the the reporting here is
saying one person has been reported to
have died from cove do you have any from
this new outbreak that's just so crazy
zero yeah you know what they also say
most people get this from omicron are
asymptomatic yeah well if zero people
died why would you have this reaction to
it ah that's a good question
right yeah and you would also think that
if our media again if our media was
looking out for your interest if they
were nationalists this is why i say
nationalism is a virtue they wouldn't be
saying hey look at the great job china
is doing they would be saying obviously
china's lying about the no deaths so uh
we're going to do our job as reporters
for this country and let you know that
there are you know there are foul games
afoot there's some we suspect foul play
in the communist chinese party we first
thought so maybe with the the
crematoriums and then we thought it was
all but acknowledged when we realized
that they said there were zero deaths
and they had an institute uh titled
covid research institute where we create
infectious diseases i'm paraphrasing but
if our media looked out for your
interest because look this could
actually not only save livelihoods
lives
lives how often has the media reported
on china lying about their numbers we
have cnn on every day look right now we
have cnn on right now right now and that
is likely a former disney employee with
that beard this is what's happening
right now on cnn they never cover it
but they want to tell you how great of a
job china is doing and how we should be
more like them there's no argument to be
made that drifting the direction of
china is any good so according um
uh also i think that what's the next
clip that we have in accordance with
china's zero covered policy they always
love us like the one child policy they
love putting numbers in their policies
yes one child
what about two one
math how about three what
zero covered policy well that's nice
that you've said it yeah yeah yeah but
they think they're like moses parting
the red seas they're going to stop like
virus
goes away oh yeah zero coveted policy a
city now uh shanghai that's 26 million
people oh that's shanghai they're now on
full lockdown
oh good
we added the music because it was boring
[Applause]
i like it no it's a happy lockdown oh
that's nice
i have to stay inside my house
i'm afraid of everything
mostly government
[Music]
don't do it
and uh by the way the streets are
completely empty because uh anyone i
don't know if you know who is breaking
quarantine they look they actually this
is a problem they were sent to jail
see
i told you something no you said wet
shirt don't break not sure ben barr
twisted help
okay yeah get it well at least they're
having fun in jail yeah yeah that's true
and they're learning about each other's
cultures
so um
when people talk about dystopian futures
uh it's already happening and it's
happening in the country that our
political representatives many of whom
not only have financial ties but they
publicly praise or in eric swalwell's
case um with whom he fornicates on a
regular basis oh it's his own
how is that guy still employed he was
banging chinese spies nothing he was
they say right up until then i mean if i
were banging chinese spies that expect
to at least get audited i mean kennedy
banged a lot of spies and we saw what
happened there not ted no no no he just
drove women into the river he was like
hey i have i have uh international
secrets like okay
yes you've drank those secrets away yes
so chinese authorities now they're
actually using drones as a way to what
to what and i'll i'll subtitle this for
you with i'll do it as accurately as i
can because it's in it's in chinese uh
remind citizens to stay home
please comply with our covered
restrictions control your soul's desire
for freedom do not open the window or
sing that's what they're saying that's
not creepy at all do not open the window
or sing that's pretty much the uh ccp
party platform control your soul's
desire for freedom yeah exactly and
there was one lady who was just opening
that uh window like i just want to say
oh no
[Laughter]
oh there she goes where is her mask now
they just have snipers you didn't die
from covet exactly
ah buried for singing yes yes
well
you know when in rome it's not kpop so
uh if you thought that was creepy the
drones uh check out this thing
that's completely unnecessary by the way
you could just use a drone that's just
to intimidate that's horrifying
hold on
well sharper image did go out of
business you're gonna do something with
all of them
so we have perfected technology to have
a a autonomous dog looking thing walking
that's not an autonomous dog it's a
remote control dog someone there's a guy
in the right side going duct tape it can
only turn wrapped the megaphone
duct tape a megaphone that's just to
scare people because they want it to
look like i am legend the drones already
do that job it's a less effective drone
but we do we have a terrifying headless
dog yeah but we don't have glue that
works
or the idea of maybe building in a
speaker you have no idea
maybe go to bose or something and see if
they can help you next is just some
animatronic goat with a teddy ruxpit on
its back
what the hell is this i love you
stay inside like this caution tape you
run out of robot dogs get real dogs get
duct tape and speak and spell put duct
tape on it work just fine
it's going to be a pigeon with a
turntable on its neck
now um this also may be the most insane
thing to come out of china again you
just saw the media praising china this
is why this matters the media doesn't
have your best interests at heart and of
course many of our representatives don't
if they praise china the only
acceptable
words to follow if you're working in the
american media a reference to china is
condemnation
for almost anything pick a subject
condemn them
because it's a communist chinese party
doesn't mean all chinese people by the
way that's the best thing you can do for
the chinese citizens as well who are
under the oppressive thumb of the
communist chinese government a lot of us
forget about them maybe the most insane
thing that i've seen coming out of uh
china you know who are doing a fantastic
job is they're absolutely insane and i
thought they're supposed to be good with
science me too the chinese yeah uh
they're coveted testing methods this is
real
they're testing a fish that doesn't have
lungs but then they give them a vaccine
for their two inflamed hearts
that is weird but at least they're not
like murdering pets or anything oh no
they actually i think i have some bad
news for you what so yeah they're
they're killing pets
all it says they're reconsidering no no
exactly nope they're reconsiderate
they're going to be killed that's what
the dog with the speaking spell taped to
its ass said exactly they're
reconsidering murdering your pets was it
a talk boy on there yeah
hello this is this is peter mckauda
stuff peeking the fava i saw you
smooching with my brother phony bob
cliff you both have covered you die
so one of the biggest problems that
residents have there's uh you know they
can't go outside
which isn't all that because if you go
outside you still find yourself in china
but um yes since they can't go outside
they're running out of food
oh wow and some are so hungry obviously
i think we have an overlay here they're
resorting to desperate measures i have
the tweet right here that i can read uh
bring this up overlay l where it's uh
they're talking about eating on wechat
eating their black neighbor to survive
the lockdown i don't know if you notice
that the chinese are incredibly racist
here's the funny thing is they were
talking on wechat
um
and the black neighbor was on wechat oh
no so that's him responding he's like
don't eat me and they're like lmao and
he's like
you know chinese
there's actually a translate button in
the app and then he says why do you want
to eat me
hey we can eat a black guy and he's like
what ah
i meant
you gray no i have a i have a blac i
have a good i have a black uh i have a
black meal have you for dinner not have
you for dinner yeah yeah you're over
yeah that's all it is the chinese with
black guests are just like a vampire
like i think our dinner together will be
delicious
it's the most terrified guy in china
right now how do you feel about dark
meat how do you feel about soul food
i eat you what i have you what for
dinner huh i eat you for dinner
i already ate all the pets on wechat and
they didn't check it's the only guy in
china on wechat with a black avatar
[Laughter]
who are you bob zapp no no no he's not
bob sapp no i'm the guy you've seen a
thousand times yeah in your building and
hurled the racial the guy who's a head
taller than everybody else and you've
seen me you know than anybody in the
country like
oh gorias that's you all right right
i thought you were david robinson no i
already told you a lot you owe david
robinson twin towers nope
and contrary to what the uh uh
media and many people like the former
ambassador claimed i don't know if you
notice people in china are actually
getting as fed up as people in china are
allowed to get fed up with the zero
coveted policy here they are
they're still very polite if that was
detroit that cop car would be on itself
for sure
[Music]
it's absolutely terrible and you know
where's the left speaking the nba won't
even mention what's going on in china
but they'll of course not they'll
support colin kaepernick from taking a
knee and so this begs the question well
why aren't they reversing their policy
as far as the lockdown policies well
this is again it's political because she
is singing he is up for a party
reelection and for those who understand
the person is selected by their party
there in china and if he's seen as weak
he's probably not going to get that seat
so this is about political expediency
it's about the fact that they've made
such a big deal out of this they have to
keep it alive in order to maintain any
votes and we see that here
directly in the united states right
they're sort of bringing it back out in
other words if we go into the midterms
and covet is no longer a thing that is
the worst case scenario for democrats
and that's why this story that you're
hearing in china and the political
ramifications may sound eerily familiar
to the rhetoric that you hear from our
scientific experts in the united states
we need to be prepared to pivot
and perhaps go back on some of the
mitigations like masking if required i
hope we don't need to go there i hope we
don't but if we do we need to be
prepared to be flexible
and really
take taper and and and guide our actions
according to what the data show yeah so
need to be flexible okay touch your toes
go jump off a bridge how about that yeah
that works how about this go jump off a
bridge first i have the science oh he
tries to play it coy he's like uh this
is what could maybe happen i hope we
don't i really hope that i don't get
elected permanently a scientific
equivalent of tenure where i have
control over everybody i really hope
that i'm not granted the right to access
all of your private records i really
hope i don't have to do lockdowns it's
on the table but i hope it doesn't have
to happen i am the science by the way
have you heard that's what they
nicknamed it's like no one nicknamed you
that well i call it myself that yeah
yeah these i really hope i don't i don't
make a new disease that gets out there
and i don't tell anybody about it and
you all get it and then i lie for a
while and i really hope that they don't
make me a backup picture for the yankees
do they see what i did after they see it
i got a very lymph-wristed toss yes
that's very good i made a baseball card
i had it immortalized on my desk it's
the first thing people see when they
enter my office i gotta have a pinch
hitter when i go to pick up the bed i
tip over yes
i also have to have a pinch hitter for
my wife she gets lippy now
what can i bring my wife
can i bring something up in this the one
of the reasons that people were getting
so pissed off in china was that they
were starting to separate kids from
their parents if the parents weren't
positive and the kids were right right
that's cool literally so here's the
thing dave and i were talking about this
at the table before the show and i was
like yeah so dave if you if you're test
negative but your kid test positive the
government comes in and forcibly removes
them from you period babies
and kids right just get that in your
head that's what the chinese government
is doing for anybody out there that's
supporting them think about that
this is again an asymptomatic disease in
their own words no no this is an extreme
example of what the left wants the state
is more important than the family unit
that's what i was talking about earlier
as far as marriage as far as why why we
have marriage laws because
self-governance can only take place if
you have a strong family unit in china
the state takes priority right takes
precedent not press it press a dense
over the family unit so yeah i want to
make sure that yeah bill richmond will
get mad at me he will it takes priority
uh it's the fast lane over the family
what do you see here you see this
exactly happening in florida
all parents are saying is we want to be
we want the right to teach our own
children about sexuality about sexual
orientation and gender and you have
people protesting and funneling in money
to the state simply for the reason that
they believe
teachers public school teachers you know
public servants
should be able to teach your children
about sexual because they know better
than you do so the extreme example china
they remove kids from their parents
because they know better than the
parents then you have a softer example
you see it happening in florida where
teachers know what's better for your
kids not only teachers but corpora but
crony corporatists at disney know how to
raise your children better than you do
and that's why look we can raise
awareness
and this is the only uh the only comedy
show that did not officially endorse
hillary clinton but we cannot enact
policy here we can hold people uh
accountable we're going to have this
guest on in a little bit let me know
token on when we when we get them up
here but um first let me uh set this up
yesterday we covered uh pretty heated
exchange it's been making the rounds
everywhere between representative gates
and uh secretary of defense
you don't understand the law so
representative you know who matt
when he comes on you don't need to do it
all right i won't but until then that's
right i appreciate you holding me
accountable i appreciate it so
representatives talked about this matt
getz and secretary of defense austin uh
over the increased wokeness uh that you
see the social engineering the far left
social engineering in the military
here's a recap i am certainly aware of
briefings that we provide to congress
but it's not just the hyper it's all
over the world it's in taiwan where
china's last year flew more sorties than
ever before it's north korea on pace to
shatter prior records the number of
missiles that they that they are testing
and so while everyone else in the world
seems to be developing capabilities and
being more strategic we got time to
embrace critical race theory at west
point to embrace socialism at the
national defense university to do
mandatory pronoun training
do you assess you know it's it's again
this is the most capable the most combat
credible force in the world it has been
and it will be so going forward
is the fact that you're embarrassed by
your by your country but no no i'm
embarrassed by your leadership i am not
embarrassed for my country i wish we
were listening to china
you know what the that's you know that
is so
that is so disgraceful that you would
sit here and conflate your failures with
the failures of the uniformed service
members
so just to give you uh some information
from those who missed yesterday's show
that i recommend you go and watch it if
you want to learn about what's going on
in the military a little bit more the
navy incurs reading from critical race
theory scholars or as the left says not
a thing boogeyman actual critical race
theory scholars founders like ibrahim x
um
uh or ibrahim x kennedy i don't know how
you pronounce it's one of those one of
those it's a [ __ ] name it's a tv
name lectures on white rage at west
point they change fitness standards for
women replacing leg tucks with planks
people can now walk 2.5 miles instead of
jogging this is what we've done and by
sorry that was a long way around to say
create the most effective fighting force
in the world yeah
well that was this whole point and again
we talked about this a little bit
yesterday but i just wanted to say like
it's it's crazy that we
i'd see that on cnn too that we have
nancy pelosi let's check nancy pelosi
this is going to she just tested
possibly but she's asymptomatic and
that's because she has no heart let's
see
a statement put out by her spokesperson
she says she's vaccinated she's fully oh
i thought she was out talking or is this
live
or they're just showing b-roll of nancy
pelosi how does a virus get in with all
that alcohol in her body yeah i know she
thinks she'll be a walking natural
disinfectant right it's just
it must have some sort of a horse trojan
horse to get it through those
she's going to be patient zero for the
next strain that actually does wipe us
out right yeah exactly exactly it's
going to find a way around yeah if it
can survive in her body we are all
doomed yes we are absolutely doomed as a
matter of fact when she blows a 0.18
that's that's that's just blood point
one eight actual blood percentage sober
is the percentage of actual human plasma
as opposed to alcohol yeah oh i see okay
that's her highest level of non-alcohol
in her veins yeah if she blows that she
could drive a car right yes
now uh and this is also we have uh
representative matt case who's gonna be
on this is also just so you know this is
why we don't often have politicians on
the show because they have a busy
schedule well no not that this is a live
show and you guys can see on cnn people
are used to in the little little known
secret in this industry none of the live
shows are actually live what yeah none
of them are live and people you know
like well i'll get to it when i get to
it so we'll give representative uh gates
another uh let's say we'll wait another
seven minutes and if he can't make it
then i guess we'll go to mug club and
chat and you guys can let him know if
you want him to come on the show but uh
come on guys we need you to hit we need
you to hit your marks
we need you to hit your marks we are
live here on this program you were about
to make a point before we realized so
secretary austin made the the
declaration that we are the the
strongest most effective you know most
powerful military in the world right now
and this this plat this what we are
doing right now will continue that and
that was the point that that
representative gates was making we are
not in florida he was making the point
that if you if you keep going down this
road that we won't and we talked about
this a little bit more in depth
yesterday but
what i want to focus on is he's trying
to deflect from a serious problem there
are people in our government who think
that your planned secretary is not going
to produce the fighting force that we
will need in the future and instead of
addressing their concerns instead of
saying we're not behind on these things
and here's why it's
you i'm sorry that you're embarrassed
for your country
he's trying to make a headline he is a
politician and nothing else in that
moment this forces me to ask people this
you know i just asked you the question
about lgbtq aaip and if that's forced
you to re-examine your position on
same-sex marriage back and they at least
go back and say you know what some
people had a point even if i disagreed
with it i've always been against women
in combat not women in the military
women in active combat i still am i
explained to you why i was back then and
not just because of the lowering of
physical fitness standards also because
of the dynamic that changes and i had we
had on this program you can go uh back
to when this was on radio on this
youtube channel probably 2014
uh sergeant catherine and she said i i
don't want any women in my platoon
because what happens is the men who
would move on in another scenario right
this whole idea of never leave a soldier
behind well that's not really true they
often do have to make judgment calls
where they leave someone and try and
leave somebody maybe with them to keep
them safe they have to make these
decisions and they wouldn't be willing
to make them if it was a woman
who was harmed and the reason why well
it's anti-patriarchy it's because men
don't want to see women on the
battlefield harmed we don't we're
actually by and large going to war at
least throughout history to protect our
women and children yeah
absolutely women and children first was
a thing a long time ago right yep well
yeah i don't think that worked out for
jack on the titanic right
and by the way she really quickly pried
his frozen hands from that raft but she
could have given it a couple of minutes
she's dead yet
[Laughter]
oh my gosh you're just you're still
shivering
your love is warming me it's an old
man's velcro shoes yeah i want to draw
you you know what that was porn back
then yes that was porn back then
she's a piece of garbage love to be a
hundred to tell everybody the story of
what piece of crap she is yup and then
she threw that you know she threw that
heart
into the ocean it's like couldn't you
get you have your kids yeah wouldn't you
like you could pay for their college
yeah there's a reason why you had that
they were all awful you threw it at a
corpse why didn't you save him yeah
maybe he could have grabbed on to it
gotten a life raft you know what maybe
you should have just kept your mouth
shut and stayed with billy zane yeah um
so this is i don't think women you guys
can comment below i don't think women
should be in active combat
and why well now we're at the point
where we're trying to build stretchier
maternity suits for women who are in
their third trimester right we've talked
about that we have that clip from pr
former vice president joe biden yeah
when my wife was pregnant they said not
to fly uh period i'm like you're putting
them in fighter jets
do you know the g-forces and what that
can do to you yeah
just the vibrations alone the hitting
like landing i mean maybe if you're
trying not to have a kid
yeah i guess yeah you shouldn't do that
though to a pregnant woman doesn't make
any sense no no well that's what we're
doing because we want to be tolerant
like look just because i'm pregnant
means that you don't think i can be up
there in a dog fight correct well it's
yes yeah that's pretty much it no no you
can but the child will die so you know
hey according to the science of you not
wanting to have a goofball
right that's what we would think yeah
oh my gosh all right i don't know why do
you think he stutters and swims in
circles oh because you're a hero right
yes
because we couldn't put anybody else up
there and your comment like the gi jane
thing right so your comment about well
we don't want that was chris rock's
comment but no no i mean the comments
don't get anybody punched jared no g.i.j
is what he's referring to i'm going back
to one when it was fine okay right going
back to the horrible film where she
fights the male instructor at the end
yeah exactly remember she's like all
right
let's do this it's like do you have any
idea how swiftly he would just harm you
yeah irreparably done just hits her once
and the movie's over yeah
it's like oh we should have just done
this for a lifetime wow well you made
the argument like we want to defend
women and they're like no no no so the
response you get from the left is no no
just treat them like male soldiers and
let whatever happens including rape and
including all these horrible things just
let it happen then we said okay but like
well we didn't mean make them do
pull-ups yeah exactly so you say okay
but then transfer that into society so
you want us to just treat you don't want
to be treated like a man you absolutely
do not want to be treated like one of
the fellows no of course okay we are
absolutely crude and rough with one
another growing up throughout life you
don't want to be in that pool for a very
good reason yeah well i don't think that
women understand that men fight each
other for words yeah i've been friends
right that happens like them's fighting
words that's not really a thing often
with women yeah i've had this
conversation with women before they've
gotten really really aggressive and i've
said look just just so you know if
you're a friend of mine who was a guy i
would i would be hitting you are you
saying you want to hit me no i'm saying
that the only reason you're talking to
me that way is because you know that i
won't gerald wouldn't be able to talk to
me that way right they will get hyperly
aggressive and personal not all women
but i'm just saying women don't
understand that's how men interact and
guess what there's a place for that in
the military you want
you want
bridled barbarianism yeah
in the military that's what we've looked
for since the beginning of time
take any example the ottomans the
mongolians the spartans
any example the american military up
until relatively recently
but you think you think you make a
military stronger by making them more
sensitive
i often uh say to men if you were a
woman i'd strike you yeah well and then
they say
if you strike me down i will become more
powerful than you can put and then
you're like you're stepping yeah just
not happy just stop the time you and
yourself
i wear a cloak
it's built into us the defendant so if a
line is being crossed you're asking us
to go against what we have been trained
to do but honestly we'll protect you in
the future right
if you're in a situation you want your
man ready willing and able to stand up
for you and defend you and your family
absolutely look and this is a question
to the women out there what kind of a
man do you want you want a man who is
easy
always during times of peace or do you
want a man who might be a little bit
more difficult during times of peace but
is uh also someone who can
be a man during a temple i think we're
gonna have to go to a mug club here are
you we'll have to go to muk club i think
he's five minutes out well you know what
we're just gonna have to do it another
time here let uh representative
representative matt getz know that uh
it's a live program we appreciate it
comment below if you want us to bring
him on here sometime soon we apologize
no hard feelings but uh we have a show
to run and actually we really have to do
our chats because we promise that to our
audience every single thursday we need
to give them a full half hour so
sorry
love you
ish i don't know you mr goetz but i i
hope that you're well and uh if we get
you on
because he said don't say gates see if i
say it it's going to screw me up comment
below if you want to bring him on here
next week uh
youtube you can piss off
i